j'ai senti votre souffle putride
derrière ma nuque fraîchement rasée
alors ne dites pas que que vous m'avez
pas poussé
mais alors comment j'ai fait alors
c'est pas vrai
non assistance à personne en danger si
on appelle ça vous savez que je pourrais
porter plainte
j'ai pas le temps de jouer
j'ai pas envie de jouer j'ai pas envie
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi m'avait poussé
non mais je vous dis franchement si
vraiment je vous ai posé je bois pas
pourquoi mais si pour me faire tomber
pour rigoler
[Musique]
les carreaux
monsieur ah ben ça se voit c'est tout
crade
[Musique]
c'est pas chez moi je sais pas où vous
voulez aller mais c'est pas chez moi là
c'est pas chez vous ici
je suis chez moi mais vous vous venez
pas laver mes carreaux ah voilà oui oui
monsieur bonjour
Comment je prends une raclette je mets
de l'eau
[Musique]
compter
sur ma vitrine moi sinon j'appelle les
flics tout de suite moi
partout vous venez de me dire finissez
mettez un coup de raclette
dans la vitrine de quel droit parce que
c'est ça
peut vous faire que ce soit sale est-ce
que je vous ai demandé quelque chose non
alors vous prenez votre matériel et puis
vous partez avec oh mais ça c'est pas
bien pour les petits artisans
non mais oh j'arrive chez vous avec une
caisse de vin je vous la dépose je vous
dis je vous l'ai monté à l'étage
maintenant vous me payez vous allez me
dire je vous ai pas commandé de 20 bon
ben moi je fais pas commander le
nettoyer mes carreaux voilà c'est tout
et si je vous commande du vin vraiment
ça c'est qu'est-ce qui vous avez fait ça
ma femme elle arrive vous allez lui
accélérer ça va lui faire plaisir allez
on passe là vous touchez là
on va se fâcher alors vous essuyez ça
s'il vous plaît tout de suite ou
j'appelle les flics moi d'accord hein
et c'est eux qui vont me régler
ça suffit
[Musique]
allez dehors attends je rentre ouais
tu m'entends mieux là
et là
là tu m'entends mieux
est-ce que tu m'entends mieux
non je comprends rien c'est ça cadet
alors
alors alors
ouais parle plus fort je n'entends pas
je n'entends pas attendez oh il y a des
clients monsieur
au téléphone mais vous êtes Vincent
jeune c'est dingue ça
mais je vois bien qu'il y a des gens et
moi je fais quoi je tricote
j'entends pas j'entends pas j'entends
pas
je suis très calme
mais j'entends rien déjà c'est assez
compliqué comme ça
je suis à côté d'une borne là et ça
grésille un peu
ouais lever le bras voir parce que ça
grésille alors
ouais allô ouais ça va
parlez pas en même temps vous voyez bien
que je suis en train de téléphoner quand
même vous venez hurlé derrière nous qui
moi alors
ouais
ouais alors
oui tu m'entends non ça grésille un peu
hein
bon ben je te laisse ciao ciao
il marche bien le ventre
c'est quoi
vous avez des extincteurs vous ici on
vous fait une petite démonstration un
petit cours théorique pratique pour bien
savoir utiliser l'extincteur donc on
tire la bobinette
et l'extincteur chira
comme ça on est copie et après on se
fait face au foyer
sur le foyer comme ça
[Applaudissements]
ça met des trucs un peu partout on tire
la chevillette vas-y
ouais
[Applaudissements]
bah des dents on a le temps de cramer
avec vous allez-y voilà hop
c'est pour ça qu'on est là c'est
obligatoire maintenant
est-ce que le feu prend rendez-vous
monsieur hop on attend que ça prenne un
peu
maintenant vous le savez on vous a tout
appris
vous pouvez me régler maintenant
attendez vous prenez une formation
professionnelle quelle formation
professionnelle droit de sa durée 30
secondes pour enlever le truc la
goupille et puis un coup sur le truc là
bah ouais non plus
mais ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire quoi
[Musique]
elles sont pas très très cuites c'est
baguettes ici je trouve moi je trouve ça
c'est à moi ça bah c'est à moi
ça oui c'est pas vous c'est pas marqué
dessus
[Musique]
j'ai déjà tout ce qui vous dise vous
allez tout là-bas au fond et vous allez
les chercher
non rien et arrêtez de m'appeler ma
chérie parce que
quoi
mon sucre
c'est un produit énergétique c'est un
nouveau c'est
à base de gingembre
ginsen café
le goût du sang de porc
de pétrole c'est une nouvelle boisson
énergétique
on sent un peu le
désir monté en soi
et au packaging vous préférez plutôt au
toucher une canette comme ça ou plutôt
une comme ça
quand même
à la prise en main
ah oui
qu'est-ce qui se passe
bah c'est vous là
je viens de prendre un coup de jus là
peut-être que vous êtes vachement
réceptive
que j'ai pris un coup de jus là
ça doit être ça moi je suis là
vous êtes pas diabétique vous n'avez pas
de problème gastrique
ça fait des trous ça c'est vous vous
sentez monter le désir en vous oui
largement on y va tout de suite
ça fait laxatif aussi
[Musique]
faut mettre du sable
[Applaudissements]
eau de mélisse quelques gouttes sur un
Sud ça brûle les doigts ça brûle les
doigts votre truc
c'est quoi c'est quoi
[Applaudissements]
vous mettez tout votre truc devant là
vous avez pas un droit à se passer la
gueule alors
[Musique]
j'appelle le médecin on constate de
votre état
suite à ça une assurance qui va prendre
en charge tous les frais tous les frais
je vais casser mes lunettes alors parce
que comme il faut que je l'échange je
vais les casser et puis on dirait que ça
arrivait pendant que je suis tombé
maintenant monsieur maintenant
je vais prendre un petit chocolat quand
même pour me remonter non vous en pensez
je vais pas vous faire payer le
teinturier quand même non je vais
prendre des chocolats ça sera mieux
faites-moi une belle boîte
pour Noël et puis on en parle plus
côté de la neige c'est vrai qu'il faut
saler mais là c'est de l'eau pour faire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que vous mettez là
la publicité
attention attention
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est ça il faut l'enlever avec un
karcher
et tu mets ça dessus ouais tu vois les
voitures qui font un peu féminées tu
mets des trucs dessus quoi et ça ça fait
une voiture féminée bon je sais pas moi
j'y connais rien en voiture tu as
entendu ce que je t'ai dit je veux pas
de publicité
tu vas voir ailleurs et puis tu me
casses les couilles alors quoi tu me
fais chier là tu comprends pas ou il
faut que je te le dise dégage lâche-moi
d'accord en plus bien FM
oh c'est gay FM
non il y a pas de honte mais on a pas le
droit avant
c'est pas incorporation pour alors
peut-être que c'est pas les leurs
hier je m'emmener des gay hier c'est pas
vrai bah si tu étais à la reine tu
connais la reine
[Applaudissements]
regardez vous le mettez chez vous non ma
femme
[Applaudissements]
je vais te taxi
sur la cabine et là vous êtes au
téléphone avec un portable dans la carte
Samsung
parce que c'est une cabine qui est sur
écoute c'est pour ça et moi je fais des
réglages fais des réglages plus
ça marche pas Madame
parce que là ça paraît un peu malsain
quand même je sais pas je comprends pas
bien c'est pas mal ça je suis désolé non
non c'est pas mal du tout monsieur
comment ça vous ennuie pas d'écouter les
conversation des gens c'est mon métier
moi on me demande de référé
s'il vous plaît vous permettez ça veut
dire ça je suis désolé vous êtes au
ministère d'intérieur ou quoi au
renseignements généraux
c'est la police
[Applaudissements]
j'étais courtois
et de fermer la porte sans arrêt si vous
voulez j'en ai pour 2 minutes
j'ai des unités qui sont des comptes
donc je paye donc foutez-moi la paix ah
je sais pas mais si tu me vois la télé
je vais en savoir pourquoi
[Applaudissements]
alors pourquoi pas
je m'en vais tout de suite j'étais
chercher un client il était pas là vous
voulez que je fasse quoi Monsieur
j'attendais une place pour me garer va
mieux feux de détresse soyez sympa chez
moi
je suis en train de faire de l'essence
monsieur
[Applaudissements]
la loi c'est la loi et la loi je m'en
fous de la Loire ah bah voilà bah vous
êtes garé n'importe comment
ça c'est toujours des excuses à deux
France 5 ans et je vous paye un coup si
vous voulez je vous donne une pièce à la
bonne heure ok bon ben donnez-moi 50
fois on en parlait ou j'avale la clé
alors de manière mais moi 50 balles
sinon je avale la clé merci
bon bah ce soir alors
comment ça se voit que j'enlève
maintenant
[Applaudissements]
chez moi alors moi je mets les trucs
aux gens qui sont malgarés devant chez
moi je suis le Robin des Bois des villes
je prends au contrôle dedans pour
m'enrichir ah c'est super et vous avez
le droit de faire ça je sais pas mais en
tout cas je le prends vous avez le droit
vous devez comme un cochon
voilà j'ai le droit bon vous allez me
donner votre nom et votre adresse et je
vais aller voir les flics pourquoi faire
quand même je vais aller voir les flics
contre vous maintenant on va faire
mon truc attention doucement mon truc
c'est fragile
stop c'est une caméra cachée
je m'en fous de la caméra moi arrête
c'est une caméra caché stop c'est une
caméra cachée
[Musique]